and what's amazing is like when I see
people or people stopped in the street
or I've seen you a couple times
placed in that way kind of you're born
and raised in London born and raised in
New York from these cities that there's
no nowhere like either Oh cities in the
world kind of we're surrounded by
culture and diversity and you meet with
people on a daily basis that are not
from your world in a way and do you
think that kind of shapes both of you as
an act as acted having you know has it
made it easier because you've been able
to connect from kind of birth with
people from all backgrounds who me
though you just have to adopt different
perspectives like my Nick door neighbor
was my next-door neighbors were Turkish
next ones were Irish like that were like
whatever like Eid or something they'll
give you presents and so you have to
adopt you have to understand you just
have to see the world differently I was
brought up to see that like the way I
live my life isn't the way everyone else
live their lives so you can when you see
characters and you're able to take on
other perspectives and empathize when
it's not black and white it's always a
great that's that's what London's kind
of taught me yeah I feel the same way
too I mean I think about it context a
family and and my mom is a third
generation new worker but my dad was
French and he moved there as I was
growing up and I've always felt like
tremendous ambiguity in the
self-identity apartment which is maybe
not great for mental health but as far
as like acting goes it's kind of great
because I don't really know what I'm
stretching from when I do rolls it's I
don't when I wash myself in things I
don't see the difference is because I
don't really know what's going on here
has the last year in a way surprised to
have your lives changed dramatically in
kind of the last 12 months with the
success of these two films yes I'm yeah
like when I'm really grateful for was
calling by her name and I can I don't
I'd be curious if this is the experience
on get out I remember being in New York
when get out came out and it really it
was like an explosion like everyone was
so excited to see and the posters were
everywhere and big great thing is like I
haven't had the total destabilizing
experience I think you can read an
interview sometimes other people where
it's really like an overnight switch or
something and what's amazing is like
when I see people or people stopped in
the street or I've seen you a couple
times that's it's always it's it hasn't
been oh you're in that show you're in
that movie it's oh you're in calling me
by our name which is a book that really
means the world to me
so that's I mean you dream about that as
an artist really like that's that's been
really nice for me to experience because
I have seen people I've admired in
interviews maybe not be so comfortable
with that but I'm like I enjoyed it any
choice is like you know but they were
the book or they like the movie have you
seen them she's in London the last time
[Laughter]
it's only you can come back to win in
the first time ever get out no I just
yeah if you go home you can go I
couldn't go home like cuz I went I went
back to do your stay so I was like yeah
okay my other what I mean and then I'd
you just get I just I always hide in it
I go like I never I just don't really
want to engage with it I just I like and
then so like now I think it's probably
got mad in their lane and I'm here so
it's great so
just like you kind of you're kind of
because I don't know how my life's
changed because it hasn't it's gone up a
notch it keeps on going up a notch and
you don't know what is the new new
normal now you know and my trainings
were here this is like this has been the
great thing about having a friendship
with Daniel is all these stops you've
been doing I don't feel like I relate to
Amy very few people in the room but I
can always lock eyes with Daniel okay
you've obviously that you've both made
some really interesting and very clever
choices to be fair in the films you've
done you know with Lady Bird and call
you by your name
Panther get out are you nervous about
kind of what you're gonna accept and
what you're gonna do next is you sir a
level now of expectation at Wow well
there's again a get out universe and a
climber named universe refusing and
nobody like that no I mean mmm yes you
know I mean again this feels like ah you
know I I'm very young and yet there have
been a lot of auditions that are knows
and meetings that are knows and projects
you're a part of they get made but
aren't necessarily well received so this
feels like appreciation time and maybe
two weeks left of having this nice kind
of moment so what comes from there will
be great I know I find the one thing I
keep in my mind is like hey you know
have this you know respect the respect
the reception if that makes any sense
and you know you you have to try and be
in the pedigree of Lady Bird or calling
our name or get out you can't you know
you can't solve that out Daniel do you
think you'll go back to writing that's
what been doing that's what I'm trying
to get out she's got mad yeah no that's
what I'm writing a TV show enough film
so I've been doing that more than acting
that's what's quite surreal for me is
kind of like like all this is I just
made a couple decisions although yeah I
did I do that and then into a wall and
because I was just kind of was like oh
man like
I just felt this urge to like to write
and got loads of ideas that I want to
like make and you just have to put the
hours in because you read them and it
got its [ __ ] I mean you just have to put
there's no shortcut you have to put yeah
I mean you don't want this you've got
you want a long cut the long cut is
always more interesting so you have to
just do the work so yeah like that's
that's kind of where my my head where
I'm where I'm heading in India and the
thing you're writing is are a part for a
young skinny now you got bomb [ __ ] yeah
we've got time for a couple of questions
in the audience so if you can wait for a
microphone can you hear me okay cool
hi my name is Gemma and I have a
question for Timothy um so throughout
call by your name you do all these like
mannerisms like when you know Oliver
gives you they don't like grow up meet
me at midnight he doesn't like twirl
kind of thing a little slide that you do
inside I was wondering like how you went
about developing like le o--'s like
mannerisms like the physicality of it
and also kind of the emotional psyche of
him also I want to say I meant to
preface this with like kind of thing
that she said but thank you both so much
for your incredible stories that are so
relevant to now and I immensely loved
both of them thank you so so much for
everything
see I'm sorry you're questioning to you
what the question sorry yeah I mean
that's the great gift of playing someone
who's finding themselves find themselves
as a person at a young age but also
their sexuality and finding their sexual
physicality is there's um there's you
know little form of that expression that
that's wrong the only thing that would
feel wrong to me is if something felt
particularly contemporary as a physical
expression or a mannerism that you
wouldn't see in the 80s but besides of
that you know I felt like I had free
license that's one of the great things
about working with a director you trust
in someone like Luca and I'm curious
this was Daniel's experience with Jordan
but when you feel like you're really
synchronised and on the same page it
gives you room to fail and I love all
the manners in the movie I love all the
slides and doorways all that but there's
a lot of that that didn't make it in
there just
was the room to try it out so as much as
I'd love to say it was one of the
control room actors you know pulling on
the knobs and dials those are moments of
spontaneity that's what I like as an
audience member I like seeing things
that feel spontaneous I thought there's
two different schools of acting two
different schools of audiences you know
and some people really like to see the
person in the control room and I like to
see real-life lived on screen it's such
a it's such a mature performance any
hoses and there's such a way that you've
really pulled back so I wonder how you
work for the league to kind of get the
idea of where like it is pull back it
could you could have gone all out this
is my she was like having a little not a
lot of experience but a ludic experience
as a young actor prior to call me by her
name and go into a drama high school and
I'm sure maybe there's actors in here or
young actors you feel a certain pressure
to bring hyperbole to not even climactic
in fact non climactic moments and you
want to indicate you want to demonstrate
how you're feeling because to your
director to the casting director you
want to go look I know what I'm doing
and that that's those aren't the
performances we love and I remember
thinking you have the gift to be a lead
of a movie hold it as close to the chest
as possible and I am an expression I
have a guy with a lot of expression so
you know where am i heart on my sleeve
without really doing it so often if I
can if I know where I am in a scene or
what I'm playing it's obvious usually
like a little too much and if I'm
genuinely in it and I don't know what's
going on and I'm trying to read and
react honestly which is scarier because
maybe you won't do something cool and
maybe you'll be awkward or or whatever
that's more real which sounds like a
cliche or cheesy or something but that's
what you're going for so that's what I
was trying to keep in mind
[Music]
[Music]